[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors en 2018 il faut absolument
s'intéresser bien sûr à l'allemagne pays
central de l'union européenne la
formation politique dans gala merkel a
perdu des plumes aux dernières élections
elle doit former un nouveau gouvernement
elle a essayé de le faire avant noël
avec les verts et avec le parti
centriste des libéraux elle a échoué
elle essaie de nouveau avec les
sociaux-démocrates qui avait promis de
ne plus jouer ce jeu là parce qu'il
avait fait dans le passé donc à l'arrêt
ce qu'elle arrivera à les convaincre
d'essayer de former un nouveau
gouvernement encore une fois ça c'est la
première chose si elles n'y arrivent pas
bien on y lit à deux alternatives soit
demandé à ce qu'on tienne de nouvelles
élections générales où alors essayé de
tenir un gouvernement minoritaire
mais elle sera très très fragile
d'autant plus qu'un nouveau parti
d'extrême droite qui a fait son entrée
au parlement au bundestag parti qui
risque de brouiller les cartes dans le
dans le jeu politique allemand ils sont
des milliers à avoir quitté le
territoire européen au cours des
dernières années pour aller combattre en
syrie ou en irak avec le groupe armé
état islamique
et maintenant que cette guerre tire à sa
fin et bien plusieurs vont chercher à
rentrer sur le territoire européen
c'est un défi majeur pour les autorités
européennes en france seulement on dit
qu'ils sont des centaines on s'attend ce
qu'il en est des centaines qui cherchent
à l'entrée sur le territoire français
alors que feras ton de ces gens est ce
qu'on arrivera à les épingler tous pour
bien sûr prévenir la commission de
nouveaux attentats terroristes sur le
territoire
qu'est ce que les autorités feront
également de leurs femmes de leurs
enfants qui les ont accompagnés qui
n'ont pour la plupart pas participé à
ces combats de quoi
pourra-t-on les accusés est ce qu'on va
les emprisonner c'est un défi majeur
pour les autorités européennes
la politique migratoire en europe va
aussi retenir notre attention dans
l'année qui vient
on l'a vu à cause des élections en
autriche
c'est maintenant un leader de droite
très conservateur le plus jeune leader
d'un pays dans le monde
ce bassin de kurt qui à 31 ans qui
dirige maintenant qui est maintenant le
chancelier de l'autriche et qui dirige
avec un parti d'extrême-droite encore
plus xénophobes
le fpr et lui attribuer la direction de
certains ministères clés comme les
affaires étrangères la défense et
l'intérieur qui sera chargé donc de
faire appliquer par sa police les
politiques migratoires à ses frontières
et qui fait écho à l'insatisfaction
générale dans les pays de l'est de
l'europe qui ne veulent plus se faire
dicter quoi faire dans les politiques
migratoires par l'union européenne et
par les dirigeants à bruxelles